un discours guerrier un de vladimir
poutine vous allez l'entendre le chef du
kremlin qui n'hésite pas à menacer ceux
qui interférerait avec la russie je vous
propose de l'écouter
c'est la
grosse de la machine star aux médias
nationaux des dodgers matt giteau a
apprécié vous déteniez méditer ip
l'idiot trois taxis ou pas c'est bien
oui vous soyez story et je nique ali
nestor
qu'est ce que ça signifie ce discours
gauthier c'est extrêmement offensif
c'est extrêmement guerrier oui c'est du
fantasme aussi quand il dit que il se
mettra en travers que la russie se
mettra en travers de toute entreprise
visant à fragiliser la sécurité des
citoyens et de l'état qui menace la
sécurité militaire de la russie
aujourd'hui personne personne l'ukraine
le répète ils veulent la paix
mais même mais même le temps vous savez
eux ce qui donne des boutons à vladmir
poutine s'est apparemment la perspective
selon laquelle on pourrait mettre des
armements en ukraine et s'il y avait une
véritable volonté belliqueuse ou
belliciste de la part de l'occident n'y
aurait pas besoin de les mettre en
ukraine vous mettez des missiles à brest
en france aux pays-bas en au royaume uni
même en allemagne et satin moscou donc
si vous voulez ce regain de tension la
question qui se pose c'est de savoir si
il est le fruit de l'imagination de
nuire poutine ou bien s'ils y croient
vraiment ou bien encore si c'est un une
manoeuvre cynique par c'est encore une
fois la sécurité du peuple russe n'est
pas en danger deuxième point la sécurité
du peuple russe on ne peut pas dire que
ce soit une préoccupation d'ordinaire
magistral primordial chez poutine c'est
tel était le cas en 22 ans de pouvoir il
aurait diversifié considérablement la
l'industrialisation d'industrie russe
pour qu' il y ait des créations
d'emplois pour qu'il y ait un certain
nombre de personnes qui émergent qui
regagne cette classe moyenne qu'il avait
contribué au début des années 2 il a
créé mais ça n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui si vous voulez quand le prix
du gaz et eau tout va bien quand ils
baissent on procède par le chômage en
russie ou par la réduction du salaire
c'est quand même invraisemblable de voir
ça dans un pays aussi riche et quand je
l'admirais poutine dit qu'il est inquiet
pour le peuple russe là encore y
croit-il peut-être qu'il s'en persuade
ou bien peut-être que c'est un fantasme